as if the scene with Atreyu and art
attacks and the swamps of sadness isn't
traumatic enough there was a horrible
urban legend that the real horse didn't
survive the film shoot what don't worry
that story is completely untrue after
filming the production even gave
Hathaway one of the horses from the film
as well as the saddle for all his hard
work unfortunately it was too
complicated to ship an animal
internationally Hathaway ended up giving
the horse to his riding double luckily
the horse went on to live for another 20
years in Germany pathway continues to
joke that he feels responsible for so
many people's childhood trauma because
of that heartbreaking scene with our tax
Hathaway has also mentioned that he
feels like he's giving fans a little
therapy when he meets them at his
convention appearances